BEGIN THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
AS WERE WAITING.
FOR OTHER MEMBERS UP TO COME --
MR QUIRK AND I WILL HOLD DOWN
THE FORT UNTIL THE OTHER MEMBERS
GET HERE HOPEFULLY SOON --
IN THE MEANTIME WE'LL WE'LL
BEGAN BECAUSE ONE BE SENSITIVE.
TO ON BE AUTHORS --
TIME -- WE
HAVE -- TWO
ITEMS ON THE AGENDA TODAY --
SO WAS BEGIN WITH MISS ALONG.
ON AJ OUR THIRTY THREE A TREATY
ON PROHIBITION OF NUCLEAR
WEAPONS YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AJ OUR THIRTY THREE
URGES FEDERAL LEADERS AND OUR
NATION TO EMBRACE THE UNITED
NATIONS TREATY ON THE
PROHIBITION OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
MAKE IT NUCLEAR DISARMAMENT THE
CENTERPIECE OF OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY POLICY AND SPEARHEAD A
GLOBAL EFFORT TO PREVENT NUCLEAR
WAR.
THE RESOLUTION ALSO CALLS UPON
OUR FEDERAL LEADERS TO AND THE
PRESIDENT'S SOUL UNCHECKED
AUTHORITY TO LAUNCH A NUCLEAR
WEAPON.
AND TO OPPOSE THE PROPOSED
SPENDING OF TRILLIONS OVER THE
COMING DECADES TO REBUILD OUR
NUCLEAR ARSENAL.
SINCE THE HEIGHT OF THE COLD WAR
THE UNITED STATESAND RUSSIA
HAVE DISMANTLED MORE THAN FIFTY
THOUSAND NUCLEAR WARHEADS BUT
FIFTEEN THOUSAND OF THESE
WEAPONS STILL EXISTS AND POSE AN
AND TOLERABLE RISKS TO HUMAN
SURVIVAL.
CITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING OHIO THE CITY IN THE
DISTRICT I REPRESENT HAVE PASSED
SIMILAR RESOLUTIONS CALIFORNIA
HAS LONG HELD THE NATION ON
IMPORTANT ENVIRONMENTAL AND
SOCIAL POLICIES AND WE MUST DO
SO AGAIN.
THIS TIME ON THE CRITICAL ISSUE
OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS I HAVE WITH
ME TODAY AT MORELIA KELLY WITH
THE TRI VALLEY'S CARE AND TO
RECLAIM IN OF THE NUCLEAR AGE
PEACE FOUNDATION TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
ARE THE RAZA.
THANK YOU TWO MINUTES APIECE OR
FIVE MINUTES ALTOGETHER OR FORM
ONE HOW MANY.
OF WHERE WE WANT TO WORK IT OUT.
WE'LL TRY TO BE SUCCINCT.
BROWN SHIRTS.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING MY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MONIQUE LIMON FOR INTRODUCING
THIS IMPORTANT RESOLUTION.
I'M RICK WOMEN ON DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE NUCLEAR AGE
PEACE FOUNDATION A NONPROFIT
HEADQUARTERED IN SANTA BARBARA.
I WE'VE GOT OVER TEN THOUSAND
MEMBERS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK.
LAST YEAR I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
PARTICIPATING IN NEGOTIATIONS AT
THE UNITED NATIONS FOR THE
TREATY ON THE PROHIBITION OF
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
AS A PARTNER ORGANIZATION OF THE
INTERNATIONAL CAMPAIGN TO
ABOLISH NUCLEAR WEAPONS AS IS MY
COLLEAGUE MARY LEAH.
AND TRY VALLEY CARES A WE SHARE
IN THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN NOBEL
PEACE PRIZE THAT WAS AWARDED FOR
OUR WORK ON THIS GROUNDBREAKING
TREATY.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT IS CHOOSING TO
SPEND OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER MINUTE FOR THE NEXT
THIRTY YEARS ON NUCLEAR WEAPONS
UPGRADES.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST DOLLARS THAT
WE'RE SQUANDERING.
NUCLEAR WEAPONS ARE
INDISCRIMINATE MASS KILLING
DEVICES.
ANY USE WOULD BE ILLEGITIMATE
AND WHOLLY UNACCEPTABLE.
CALIFORNIA HAS A LONG AND PROUD
HISTORY OF SETTING POSITIVE
LEGISLATIVE TRENDS AND KICK
STARTING THE PROCESS OF CHANGE
NATIONWIDE.
THAT'S WHY AJ OUR THIRTY THREE
IS SO IMPORTANT TODAY.
THE RESOLUTION LAYS OUT SOME OF
THE CATASTROPHIC HUMANITARIAN
CONSEQUENCES THAT COULD OCCUR
SHOULD NUCLEAR WEAPONS BE USED
AGAIN.
I'VE WORKED CLOSELY WITH PEOPLE
AROUND THE WORLD WHO HAVE BEEN
DEEPLY IMPACTED BY NUCLEAR
WEAPONS DEVELOPMENT TESTING IN
USE AND EVERYONE OF THEM TELLS
ME THE SAME THING.
WE MUST PUT AN END TO NUCLEAR
WEAPONS SO THAT NO ONE EVER
SUFFERS THE SAME FATE.
THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA NOW HAVE
A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THIS NOBLE GOAL.
FOR FIFTY YEARS THE U. S. HAS
BEEN PART OF THE NUCLEAR
NONPROLIFERATION TREATY WHICH
HAS BEEN REMARKABLY SUCCESSFUL
AT PREVENTING THE SPREAD OF
NUCLEAR WEAPONS TO ADDITIONAL
COUNTRIES.
BUT IT HAS FAILED TO COMPEL THE
NUCLEAR ARMS STATES TO FULFILL
THEIR OBLIGATION TO NEGOTIATE IN
GOOD FAITH FOR AN END TO THE
NUCLEAR ARMS RACE AND FOR
NUCLEAR DISARMAMENT.
THE HUNDRED TWENTY TWO NATIONS
THAT VOTED IN FAVOR OF ADOPTING
THE TREATY ON THE PROHIBITION OF
NUCLEAR WEAPONS WERE COMPLYING
WITH THEIR OBLIGATION TO ACT.
THE U. S. WAS SHAMEFULLY HOSTILE
TO THIS PROCESS THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE WORLD'S
COUNTRIES ARE MOVING FORWARD TO
OUTLAW IN STIGMATIZED NUCLEAR
WEAPONS POSSESSION IN THE U. S.
IS BEING LEFT BEHIND.
THIS EMERGING LEGAL NORM AGAINST
NUCLEAR WEAPONS WILL ONLY GET
STRONGER.
CALIFORNIA FOLLOWED BY THE
ENTIRE UNITED STATES MUST GET ON
THE RIGHT SIDE OF HISTORY.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY WE MUST DO
EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER TO
ELIMINATE NUCLEAR WEAPONS BEFORE
THE ELIMINATE US [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING.
I'M MARY LEAH KELLY I'M
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR TRI
VALLEY CARES WERE A LIVERMORE
CALIFORNIA BASED NONPROFIT WITH
FIFTY SEVEN HUNDRED MEMBERS.
TRI VALLEY CARES IS MONITORED
NUCLEAR WEAPONS ACTIVITIES AT
CALIFORNIA'S LAWRENCE LIVERMORE
NATIONAL LAB FOR THIRTY FIVE
YEARS.
AND WE ARE UNIQUE IN THAT OUR
MEMBERSHIP INCLUDES AND HAS
ALWAYS INCLUDED SCIENTISTS AND
ENGINEERS FROM THE LABORATORY
WHICH IS ONE OF TWO LOCATIONS
THAT DESIGNS EVERY NUCLEAR
WEAPON IN THE UNITED STATES
ARSENAL.
I TOO HAD THE HONOR OF
PARTICIPATING AT THE UNITED
NATIONS AND NEGOTIATIONS FOR THE
TREATY ON THE PROHIBITION OF
NUCLEAR WEAPONS LAST SUMMER.
THE TREATY MAKES CLEAR THAT
NUCLEAR WEAPONS POSE HORRIFIC
HUMANITARIAN AND ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSEQUENCES THAT ARE LEGALLY
AND MORALLY UNACCEPTABLE UNDER
ALL CIRCUMSTANCES.
THE TREATY WAS OVERWHELMINGLY
ADOPTED BY ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWO STATES PARTIES LAST
YEAR.
PUTTING THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
COUNTRIES OF THE WORLD ON
RECORD.
SPEAKING IN A SINGLE VOICE THAT
NUCLEAR WEAPONS ARE NO LONGER
ACCEPTABLE.
THIS IS HOW SOCIETAL PATTERNS
ARE CHANGED.
THIS IS HOW NATIONAL BEHAVIORS
ARE CHANGED OVER TIME.
BY VOTING TO PASS AJ OUR THIRTY
THREE THIS COMMITTEE BECOMES AN
INTEGRAL PART OF THIS GLOBAL
SHIFT TO PUBLIC SAFETY BASED ON
A NUCLEAR WEAPONS FREE WORLD FOR
OUR CHILDREN AND FOR ALL WHO
FOLLOW.
IT'S RIGHT TIMELY AND FRANKLY
THRILLING TO ME IS A CALIFORNIAN
--
THAT MY STATE IS POISED TO TAKE
A PRINCIPLED POSITION TO HELP
ENSURE THAT NUCLEAR WEAPONS ARE
NEVER AGAIN USED.
THAT THE INTERNATIONAL TRADING
ON THE PROHIBITION OF NUCLEAR
WEAPONS IS SUPPORTED.
AND THAT THE ELIMINATION OF
NUCLEAR WEAPONS OCCURS AT THE
EARLIEST POSSIBLE DATE.
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU
PERSONALLY AND FROM MY GROUP.
ARE ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON FOR
INTRODUCING AJ OUR THIRTY THREE
AND I WANNA THANK ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY FOR CONSIDERING
THIS RESOLUTION AND FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SPEAK THIS MORNING BEFORE
YOUR MOST IMPORTANT VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENT OTHER ANY OTHER --
ANYWHERE ELSE IN SUPPORT HIS
NATION POLICE.
THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
I MY NAME IS SO ROBERT GOULD ON
PRESIDENT OF OF SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA CHAPTER PHYSICIANS FOR
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY ALSO PAST
PRESIDENT OF OUR ORGANIZATION.
REPRESENTING THOUSANDS OF
PHYSICIANS AND HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AROUND THE COUNTRY
WHO STRONGLY SUPPORT THE ASSAULT
ONLY JUST ADD. TO THE RECORD
THAT JUST LAST WEEK PEOPLE
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE IN A
MANNER SIMILAR TO AGING OUR
THIRTY THREE PASSED SIMILAR
RESOLUTIONS IN BALTIMORE AND LOS
ANGELES.
INDICATING THE REAL UPTAKE OF
THIS FROM PEOPLE IN OUR COUNTRY
THANK YOU FOR CONDUCTING THESE
HEARINGS [inaudible]
YOU.
I DOCTOR BUILDERS AND PRESIDENT
OF THE SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF
PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NOW STEVE TELL YOU ARE AS AN
INDIVIDUAL AND I SUPPORT THIS IS
STRONG THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible] TWO HR.
ARE ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MISTER QUIRK --
SO BUT FIRST WELL I CAN VOTE FOR
THIS AS YEARS.
BOB BUT THERE ARE SOME --
TECHNICAL --
QUESTIONS I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
WANT TO GET THEM.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT THEM LATER IF
YOU.
WE'VE WE'VE BEEN YES WIENER WE
ARE WE HAVE BEEN AT IT'S BEEN
SHARED WITH US THAT YOU HAVE
SOME AT TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
POTENTIALLY AND WE WOULD BE
HAPPY TO HAVE THAT DISCUSSION
AND OKAY ESPECIALLY IBM
EUROSPORT AS HIS BECAUSE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS ARE PRETTY HARA.
THANK YOU YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENT [inaudible]
FROM.
YOU MAY CLOSE MITCHELL MONTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU LINDA AND AND I WOULD
--
STRONGLY URGE YOU --
TO SPEAK TO THE DOCTOR QUIRK.
ABOUT ISSUE AS HE MAY BE THE
ONLY PERSON IN THIS BUILDING.
NO DEFECT TO THE SCIENTISTS HERE
TO MATCH ACTUALLY KNOW HOW THIS
WHOLE PROCESS WORKS ABSOLUTELY
AND THEY HAVE SOME FAMILIARITY.
DADDY PUBLIC CAN'T SHARE GOOFY
DOES SHE HAVE TO KILL YOU.
BUT I THINK YOU'LL BE VERY VERY
VERY HELPFUL [inaudible]
AND ENSURING.
AS YOU CRAFT THIS DATA HOME --
THE WORDING IS IS VALID THEM IN
THAT IF THERE'S ANY TYPE OF
CORRECTION THEY NEED TO BE MADE.
I WOULD STRONGLY --
ASK YOU TO TO CONSIDER THEM
FOUND SKETCH AND GET WITHOUT IT.
THE CHURCH RECOMMEND AND I VOTE.
MATT SECTOR.
HOSES ANITA THIS --
GOT STEP OKAY WITH THE STEP WAS
A QUORUM BECAUSE MISTER KILEY
CAME.
JONES SAWYER I I'M HERE LACKEY
[inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
CORMS ESTABLISH.
ON AJ OUR THIRTY THREE MOTION IS
TO BE ADOPTED JONES SAWYER AYE
AYE [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY.
IS THAT RIGHT [inaudible]
QUIRK.
YEAH QUIRK I SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
NEED ONE MORE VOTE.
MONDAY ABSENT MEMBERS RETURN I
THINK YOU.
GET THAT DONE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
BOTH.
NOW WE HAVE AJ ARE --
THIRTY RESTRICTING USE OF
NUCLEAR WEAPONS ACT OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN MISS.
AB WE ARE CURRY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS BLOOM AJ OUR THIRTY
CALLS ON CONGRESS TO SWIFTLY
PASSED.
HR. SIX NINE WHICH PROHIBITS THE
PRESIDENT FROM UNILATERALLY ALL
THE FOR AUTHORIZING THE
OFFENSIVE USE OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS
WITHOUT A CONGRESSIONAL
DECLARATION OF WAR.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE PRESIDENT
HAS THE SOLE AUTHORITY TO ORDER
THE USE OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS WITH
NO OUTSIDE REVIEW REQUIRED.
HERE SHE MAY CONSULT WITH
CONGRESS BUT IS NOT REQUIRED TO
DO SO.
IF ANY PRESIDENT BORDERS AN
OFFENSIVE NUCLEAR ATTACK ON ANY
OTHER NUCLEAR POWER.
THE RESPONSE WOULD BE AN
IMMEDIATE COUNTERATTACKS
RESULTING IN UNSPEAKABLE
AMERICAN CASUALTIES.
HR SIX SIX NINE WOULD FIX THIS
THREAT BY MAKING SURE CONGRESS
HAS A SAY IN SOMETHING THAT
COULD IMPACT EVERY SINGLE PERSON
IN THE UNITED STATES.
PASSING AJ OUR THIRTY
DEMONSTRATES CALIFORNIAS
COMMITMENT TO PROTECTING ALL
AMERICAN PEOPLE FROM THE TERROR
OF A NUCLEAR WAR.
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT IS
JASON BARBOSA OF THE YEAR UNION
OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHEN MEMBERS MY
NAME'S JASON BARBOUR US WITH
THAT UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS.
AND OUT THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TEST Y. SUPPORT
OF THIS RESOLUTION WE'RE
GRATEFUL TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY.
FOR GIVING VOICE TO THIS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TOPIC.
MY ORGANIZATION HAS WORKED
THROUGHOUT IT'S NEARLY FIFTY
YEAR HISTORY TO REDUCE THE RE ON
URGENT THREAT.
OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS WHICH TO THIS
DAY POSES AN EXISTENTIALIST
THREAT. TO ALL OF HUMANITY AS
WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING THIS
MORNING.
TODAY IT NEARLY FIFTEEN THOUSAND
NUCLEAR WEAPONS REMAIN ON THE
PLANET.
MOST POSSESSED BY THE U. S. IN
RUSSIA.
IN A DETONATION OF EVEN AT
RELATIVELY FEW OF THEM COULD
LEAD TO CATASTROPHIC HUMAN
ECOLOGICAL AND ECONOMIC
CONSEQUENCES.
GRAVELY AFFECTING EVERY SINGLE
PERSON ON THE PLANET.
UNDER THE CURRENT PROCEDURES AS
WAS JUST DISCUSSED THE PRESIDENT
UNITED STATES HAS SOUL AND
UNCHECKED AUTHORITY TO USE THE
ORDER THE USE OF NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
THE SYSTEM IS RISKY.
UNNECESSARY AND UNJUSTIFIED.
AND WITH THAT MIND YOU SEE S.
WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREES THAT NO
PERSON.
THIS PRESIDENT NOR ANY OTHER.
SHOULD HAVE THE SOLE UNCHECKED
AUTHORITY TO ORDER THE FIRST USE
OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
THERE ARE PRACTICAL WAYS TO
INCLUDE MULTIPLE DECISION
MAKERS.
IN ORDERING ANY USE OF NUCLEAR
WEAPONS THE UNITED STATES SHOULD
ADOPT SUCH CHANGES.
THE SIMPLE FACT IS WE DON'T WANT
NUCLEAR WEAPONS TO EVER AGAIN BE
USED AS THEY WERE USED BY UNITED
STATES SEVENTY THREE YEARS AGO.
THIS RESOLUTION AND MANY OTHER
LOCAL AND STATE INITIATIVES
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY ARE
SENDING A POWERFUL SIGNAL TO
WASHINGTON THAT WE MUST QUICKLY
CHANGE COURSE.
AND URGENTLY WORK TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER AND ROLE OF NUCLEAR
WEAPONS IN OUR SECURITY POLICY.
AND FUNDAMENTALLY REFORM U. S.
NUCLEAR WEAPONS POLICY.
ENDING THIS SOLE AUTHORITY
POLICY IS JUST ONE OF MANY
CRITICAL CHANGES --
IN U. S. NUCLEAR WEAPONS POLICY
THAT ARE NECESSARY TO REDUCE THE
REAL AN URGENT THREAT OF THESE
WEAPONS --
AND WE THANK YOU ALL FOR
CONSIDERING THIS RESOLUTION
TODAY AND FOR BRINGING ATTENTION
LEADERSHIP THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
THANK YOU HOMES WITHOUT.
BUT ARE THERE ANY OTHER --
MEMBERS HAVING PEOPLE WANTED
SUPPORT [inaudible]
DJ ARE.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
HELLO THEN DOCTOR ROBERT GOULD A
WITH PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT DODD THIS INITIATIVE AS
WELL TO PROTECT OUR POPULATIONS.
IT'S ALSO IN LINE WITH THE WHAT
DOCTOR GEORGE LUNDBERG SET WROTE
--
LAST -- TWO
YEARS AGO ACTUALLY JUST BEFORE
THE ELECTION.
WHO'S HE UP THE EDITOR OF
MEDSCAPE AND FORMER EDITOR OF
THE JOURNAL MEDICAL --
JOURNAL AMERICAN MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION THAT WE NEED TO TAKE
THESE STEPS IT'S MORE THAN THE
PARTICULAR INDIVIDUAL THAT'S
SYSTEMS THAT WE HAVE A WE REALLY
HAVE TO PUT THESE TYPES OF
CONTROLS TO PROTECT US THANK YOU
[inaudible]
YOU.
DOCTOR BUILDER XIN ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF PHYSICIANS
FOR SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
IF YOU.
MORNING ASKING SILVA WITH BEYOND
THE BOMB HOMEWORK GRASSROOTS
MOVEMENT TO PREVENT NUCLEAR WAR
--
FOR US WE SEE THIS NOT ONLY
OBVIOUSLY IS A SAFETY ISSUE BUT
A CONSTITUTIONAL AND ISSUE THERE
ARE NO CHECKS AND BALANCES RIGHT
NOW ON OUR GOV ON THE NUCLEAR
SYSTEM AND OUR GOVERNMENT IS
BASED ON CHECKS AND BALANCES AND
AND SO AUTHORITY AND OUT THOSE
CHECKS AND BALANCES.
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO US
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
RICK WOMEN NUCLEAR AGE PEACE
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TRY VALLEY CARES LIVERMORE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
IF YOU.
STEVE CALAVERAS STRONGLY.
THANK YOU SIR.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS [inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
SO.
YOU ARM I CAN THE SUPPORT THIS
SAYS IS THERE'S A FEW TECHNICAL.
THINGS THAT WE MIGHT CHANGE.
I THINK THE IMPORTANT THING TO
REALIZE IS THAT WE HAD A FIRST
USE POLICY IN THE COLD WAR
BECAUSE WE WERE WORRIED ABOUT
THE SOVIET UNION --
AND THEIR EASTERN ALLIES
OVERWHELMING OUR TROOPS IN
GERMANY.
OB THAT'S NO LONGER --
THEY NO LONGER HAVE THAT
ABILITY.
NOT CLEAR THAT THEY EVER DID.
AND SO THIS HAV RELIC FROM THE
COLD WAR SHOULD BE ABOLISHED I'M
VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT.
OF A BALLOT OF HAVING A NO FIRST
USE POLICY FOR MANY REASONS.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK --
I WOULD BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION WITH
YOU ON THIS.
YES MR KAMLAGER-DOVE JUST HAVE A
COMMENT I TOO WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BUT TO YOUR COMMENTS AN
EQUALLY GREAT ISSUE.
IS THE MENTAL ACUITY INSTABILITY
OF THOSE WITH THE AUTHORITY TO
PUSH THE BUTTON REGARDLESS OF
WHO THEY ARE.
SO HOPEFULLY THE TALK ABOUT THAT
AT SOME POINT SOON [inaudible]
TO THANK YOU.
ARE ANY OF QUESTIONS COMMENT.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
I WITH US THAT THEY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND AS THE AUTHOR
BEFORE -- I
BUT I ENCOURAGE YOU.
TO TALK TO DOCTOR QUIRK AND DOES
IT MAKE JUST A STRONG AND AJ ARE
AS POSSIBLE [inaudible]
LIKE.
I MISSED QUIRK HASN'T TOLD ME
ANYTHING BUT IF I WERE TO SHARE
WITH YOU I DON'T WANT HIM TO TRY
TO KILL ME HE SAID.
SO.
A I WOULD.
BIRGITTA TO ENLIST HIS SUPPORT
IN AND GETTING THIS DOCUMENT IS
AS TIGHT AS POSSIBLE
THINK I SO CHAIRS RECOMMENDED
AYE VOTE SECRETARY.
CALDERON AJ OUR THIRTY MOTION TO
BE ADOPTED JONES SAWYER AYE
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NOT VOTING CARDIO.
CARDIO I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I KILEY.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE.
THAT PASSES THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK [inaudible]
AND NOW [inaudible]
WE'LL GO.
HR THIRTY THREE FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ON AJ THIRTY THREE LACKEY.
LACKEY NOT VOTING CARDIO.
MCCARTY ARE AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE.
COME LEVEL LONGER DOES AYE.
KILEY.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THAT WE HAVE NO OTHER.
ITEMS ON THE AGENDA.
PUBLIC SAFETY STAND ADJOURNED